[Music]
welcome to Google next and welcome to
this talk on designing quality api's I'm
glad to see a reasonably good turnout I
did want to give a presentation here in
in San Francisco and I was scheduled in
a back room at the same time as the
keynote presentation with some
reasonably famous speaker I can't
remember who it was and when it came
time to start the session there was
exactly one person in the audience
sitting in the front row and I was just
sort of considering what to do at this
point when some fellow wandered in
through the back door and it was fairly
obvious from the way he was behaving
that he was completely lost he didn't
know where he was so I gave him an
extremely warm welcome and thanked him
for showing up to my to my session so of
course at this point this poor fellows
stuck I've sort of cut off his line of
retreat so anyway the three of us sat in
the front row and just sort of chit
chatted and for an hour so I'm very very
happy that so many of you have turned up
for this talk
so I assume you're here because you're
interested in api's and if you're
interested in API you'll know that
there's lots of controversy around API s
and there's lots of conflicting advice
on what to do my experience is when that
happens it's often the case that people
aren't really disagreeing about
technology the reason that they disagree
is that they come to the problem with
with different ideas and different
values different they have different
objectives they're trying to solve
different problems and so since they're
actually trying to solve different
problems they tend to disagree about the
solutions so I thought I'd take a moment
to talk about some of the different
things that people are actually trying
to achieve when they approach the
problem of developing an API this is a
picture of Richard Hamming you probably
heard of Richard Hamming is a famous
person and in computer circles he was a
sort of mathematician and scientist of
the 20th century's famous for Hamming
codes which are error correction and
detection codes which are actually still
use
today they used in RAM memory and they
used in wireless protocols one of the
things that Hamming was famous for in
addition to having windows Hamming
distance
I mean codes and he was famous for a
series of lectures that he gave and you
can find those lectures on the internet
now you've this versions on YouTube as
well as written versions and one of the
most famous is called you and your
research which is his advice to
researchers on how to maximize their
impact and manage their careers and
hamming himself says that although he's
his experiences from research his advice
is useful in in different kind of
domains and so having makes them both
some important points some useful points
if you really want to have an impact and
then you should make sure that you're
working on problems are really important
problems in your field if you're not
working on the important problems it's
unlikely that you'll do important work
another point that he makes and in fact
this is a great talk if you're not
familiar with Hemmings lecture then you
should go and spend some time looking at
it in fact the truth is if you only had
one hour to spend you probably do better
to spend it listening to Hamming than
listening to me but I'm gonna assume
that you have two hours to spend so
you're gonna spend one hour listening to
me and then when are listening to
Hamming and the other thing that having
talks about is this idea of having an
attack on a problem and for him an
attack is kind of a possible approach
that might lead to a solution to the
problem or at least make a dent in the
problem and in fact he says that there
are the three greatest problems in
physics for problems that he never
worked on and really nobody else ever
worked on during his career and those
three problems were time travel
teleportation and anti-gravity and it's
not that those weren't problems who's
for which a solution would it would have
had an impact it would have actually
changed the world and it would have
given you a reputation that would have
lasted centuries along with your with
your Nobel Prize but the problem is
nobody has a faintest idea how to attack
those problems how to approach those
problems and therefore it's a waste of
time I'm sort of working on them so good
problems have the characteristic that
they are really important in their
impact and your some idea how to tackle
them
so if we bring this back to the world of
api's one very common way to think about
an API and the purpose of an API is that
it's a way the two pieces of software
can communicate across the network I
have a client and a server the client
needs to get at data or to invoke
actions on the server and we want the
communication to be fast secure and easy
to program so it seems like many people
come at api's with that as sort of the
problem definition and that's actually
not at least by hemmings definition an
important problem in our field that
doesn't mean that it's not important you
know that could be very I've worked on
many projects where those were you know
solving that problem was important but
this is actually a solved problem there
are several good technologies for doing
this and you just have to pick one if
you think that this is what this is what
your primary problem is here are some
different goals that you might have if
you're defining an API and these are
important problems in our field and
these are unsolved problems so one
important problem is that software is
just basically hard to change and every
Enterprise that I've ever worked in or
every Enterprise that I've had contact
with and worked and worked alongside
with which is a much larger number and
has had the problem that they're
essentially prisoners over their
existing software you know you build up
and then unless you're in the first few
months of a startup you have a legacy of
existing software and it's never what
you want it's never what you want for
your business needs the the business
scenarios change the business needs to
change and it's never really what you
want from a technical point of view
either you know once you've done
something you always immediately learn
how you could have done it better and so
you but but you're stuck with it and
it's difficult to change is difficult to
change because it's complicated and it's
difficult to change because in almost
all the systems that we have they're
permeated with assumptions we have
difficulty containing the assumptions
that we make whether those are technical
assumptions about which databases are
which technologies are which
implementation languages we use or
whether those are business assumptions
about what actually this
Cheerios are that the system has to
support which is also something that's
changes software is very also very hard
to integrate and integration is a huge
issue especially in well you know in all
of the enterprises that I have worked in
every almost all the enterprises that
I've worked with of some kind of
initiative to get a 360 degree view of
the of the problem which is basically
how do i integrate all the information
that i have about a customer or they're
trying to integrate the total experience
there are many points of contact with a
customer and they're trying to integrate
those things together and many of you
will have traveled here to the
conference when you made your booking
that's a big integration app dealing
with hotel reservations your credit card
you know your flight reservations and
things like that and when you go back
and do your expense report assuming the
use of a reasonably modern sort of
expense report tool which I'm sure most
of you have that's another big
integration app that's integrating your
credit card bills if it's a nice modern
application your flight receipt and your
hotel receipt will already be known in
your expense report and associated with
your trip that kind of thing so a big a
big kind of integration app so a huge
amount of the development that I see is
in fact integration development we build
up these little sort of silos and then
we realize that there's a large amount
of value if we can if we can integrate
those silos and software's hard to
integrate often because basic KPIs are
not available so it becomes it's
difficult when you can't get at the data
that you want you want to do and also
because it's an N squared problem every
system has its own unique API so if you
try to do an integration thing you get
to learn you get you get to learn the
api's of all of the systems that you're
trying to integrate I believe that some
styles of API go beyond the first
problem they go beyond simply efficient
easy to program communications between
two distributed components and they
offer a
second attack on those two major
problems because there are other major
problems in software like software
quality is a huge problem but I don't
have an attack on that one so I left
that off my list but I think API is
providing an attack on those two major
problems there are two dominant styles
of API one is the NTU entity oriented
style sometimes called rest I'll come
back to that word in a minute and in
that style the client code manipulates
the entities that are exposed by the
server and the behaviors of the system
are hidden behind those entities what I
deal with is the entities themselves I
can create entities I can update
entities I can relate entities to each
other what the system actually does is a
side effect of those entity based sort
of operations and an older-model
is the procedure oriented model the sort
of RPC model and that one is the perfect
inverse in that one what I what I
interface with is the procedures that
you provide and the entities that those
procedures are talking about are hidden
behind the procedures so one puts the
entities in front of the behaviors the
other one puts the behaviors in front of
the entities there are inverses of each
other here's my kind of stylized thing
and actually you probably annoyed at
this chart I'm a little annoyed at this
chart because it's trying to make a
point which I actually believe is true
and and the point that is trying to make
is that in procedure in the procedure
oriented style typically what you end up
with is a very large number of these
procedures that you have to master so
there's a lot of these a lot of these
basic procedures or functions that you
call that that you learn a long list of
the entity oriented style has more
structure and the problem with this
chart is that it's not really it's not
really balanced on each side the
procedures that I'm showing actually
imply a number of different entities
there's the dog there's the owner of the
dog there's the veterinary surgeon the
deals with the health of the dough of
the dog so if this were really a
balanced one I would have multiple
entities on the left hand side but the
point that is trying to make is that
there's much more structure on the left
hand side the left hand side is like an
ER diagram an entity relationship
diagram I understand what the basic
entities are I understand the
relationships between them but the
actual methods that I call are very
limited and they're always the same in
the procedure the procedure oriented
style is very similar to learning the
libraries of a programming language and
I think this is one of the reasons why
RPC has been parentally popular with
programmers because it's very familiar
you learn a programming language you
learn the libraries of the programming
language and learning distributed API
that is written in the RPC style is just
like learning another library it's not
really very very different from that but
one of the characteristics is all of
those api's are different the entity
oriented style is much more similar to
learning to use a database so one of the
characteristics is if you use whatever
your favorite database is my sequel or
Postgres or Oracle or whatever it is a
fundamental characteristic is that there
is only one API it doesn't matter how
many databases you have the database
management system that hosts that
database defines a single API that's
used for all of them so you only ever
learn one API now when you go from
database to database you have to learn
the schema of that of that database you
have to learn the tables and what are
the tables and then you have you learn
what are the columns in that table or if
you're using my sequel database the
terminology changes a little bit but the
concepts don't change very radically so
the entity oriented approach has this
very interesting characteristic of of
solving the N squared problem instead of
having an individual API for each system
I have one universal API this used with
all the systems and I give this talk
well I practiced this talk I'm not
actually very it's not very common for
me to practice talks but Google Google
wants us to do the best that we can for
you guys so I
encouraged to practice this talk and
when I give this talk internally
somebody said are you really telling me
that my API should just show issue just
be a view onto my database and the
answer is no that's not what I'm saying
what you actually store in your database
is probably more complicated you may
have multiple tables for each entity you
may not even have tables for your entity
your entities may be assembled from
information that you get from other
services so it's not about taking your
database schema and just exposing it as
your API but it is about using the same
kind of concepts the same conceptual
model for an API that you see used for a
database um so if we're going to take
these important problems it was there
our problems was it's hard to change and
it's hard to integrate some of the
characteristics from API is especially
the entity oriented API is that will
help us here is one is having a uniform
API across all applications that helps
with our N squared problem another one
is having a uniform model for
relationships I'll talk a little bit
more about why relationships are so
important in this and then the third one
is staying free of implementation
assumptions so how do we get that from
from this kind of entity oriented API I
said it come back to the rest term REST
API is actually a little bit of an
oxymoron because the one of the primary
rules of rest is what was rest ret rest
was rest was one man's attempt to write
down the architectural principles that
underpinned the HTTP web so it's really
a description of the architectural style
are the architectural principles of the
HTTP web and one of those principles is
uniform interface which means that it
really only is one interface so when we
talk about a REST API there's only one
important REST API in the world and
that's HTTP so when we talk about REST
API is what we're really talking about
is how do we just use HTTP just use it
just be exactly as it is and apply it to
the domain of API is really what we're
saying is don't leer concepts on top of
HTTP just use it as is it is the univer
Universal API
unfortunately HTTP has some gaps here
HTTP actually tell
you how to do crud in a nice way
HTTP does not tell you how to do query
for example and query turns out to be
very important for almost all API s and
neither does it tell you how to do
versioning so there is some amount of
invention required beyond the sort of
universal API that's provided to us by
HTTP and how do you actually leverage
this uniform API this HTTP API well
again it's a lot like it's a lot like
what you would do with a database the
first thing you have to do is you have
to define a few well-known URLs you know
for example slash customer slash account
slash orders which is very analogous to
defining what the tables are if I'm
defining a database schema and then I
have to define the actual resource
schema which is very analogous to
defining what are the columns for each
one of those entities and then the rest
of the problem is don't mess up the
basics so when we have to start adding
query and adding versioning and things
like that do it in a way that's
compatible with this standard API that
we want to that we want to show and so
here's something that's very typical so
here's kind of simplified version and if
you've worked at all in sort of you know
HTTP Jason api's I shouldn't think is
very much here that's not familiar to
you and but the thing that I'm
highlighting is this ID : one two three
four five and when you do that you've
already stepped outside the uniform
interface and the reason is that the
uniform interface that we're trying to
use the HTTP interface requires URLs it
doesn't require simple numeric IDs so if
I'm gonna write my U if I'm gonna write
my identifiers this way I'm going to
require extra information about my about
my API I'm gonna have to describe in the
documentation how you take one of those
your IDs and how you transform it into a
URL that can then be used in the API and
this was unfortunate because it would
have been just as easy to do that and if
I done that instead then now I stay
within the Uniform API
I don't require you to have extra
out-of-band information about my API in
order to use the universal the universal
API which is HTTP so very small change
but these things sort of make a
difference when they're accumulated
relationships are extremely important
relationships are extremely important
when you're designing a database and
they're also extremely important when
you're designing a an API one of the
reasons is that API is the the
fundamental problem in most integration
projects is creating relationships
between entities that are stored in
different in different applications
sometimes I'm trying to get at function
through a particular API but in many of
the you know the integration examples
that I gave earlier for example your
expense reports or your travel booking
are all about relating entities to each
other you know I'm taking I'm taking
this this flight along with this hotel
reservation and I'm looking to get I'm
linking them all together with this trip
ID so I'm relating entities in different
systems and relationships are a very
fundamental way about whether we think
you know thinking about the world in
terms of entities and relationships is
an idea that goes at least back to Plato
and Aristotle I put their pictures here
just in case you come across them at the
conference and want to talk to them a
major obstacle and identity depends on
sorry relationships depend on identity I
cannot reason about a relationship and
less I can reason about identity I can't
say john loves Mary
unless I can reliably identify John and
reliably identify Mary and so one of the
primary obstacles to these kind of
relationship based integrations through
api's is the struggle that we have with
identity and here the universal API the
HTTP API makes a huge contribution by
defining the concept of a URI or a URL
which gives us the ability to across all
of our systems write identifiers in a
way that's standard and repeatable and
store
all of those kind of things but again we
tend to make mistakes here so here's
here's what yours in a I'm particularly
got the wrong pointer here so here focus
on this last line so this is a very
typical way that you'll see people
writing are attempting to write
relationships in a typical sort of JSON
API you know the right owner ID owner
ideas are is the field that I've used to
capture the owner and I give its numeric
identifier now the problem with this is
that this identifier I need a lot of
contextual information I cannot just use
the Uniform API to follow this link
because I need contextual information I
need to know where I plug this it which
other systems can I plug this value into
and how do I plug that in in a way that
creates a URL that I can then use and in
fact this breaks down in different ways
I mean supposing I have different kinds
of owners you know some owners are
police dogs right so or rather police
dogs have a different kind of owner in
that case the owner of the dog might not
be a person that might be the police
department or something like that so how
do I know how do I know to resolve this
number by looking in in the system of
institutional owners as opposed to
personal owners those kind of things and
we could have avoided all of those
problems if we'd simply written it this
way
in other words owners the relationship
and give a URL if the URLs in the same
system you can like write it relatively
I can resolve a relative URL knowing
only the standard specifications you
know published by IETF I don't have to
know anything specific about your your
URLs or your systems to do that or if
this reference is something in another
system then I write the URL in its full
form and you might think about how you
do how do you do this kind of example
with our PC with our PC is probably even
more complicated with our PC you have to
take something like this and then you
have to know amongst all of the all of
the remote procedures that I could
call which are the ones that will take
something like this as an argument
so is that having a uniform a model for
identities in Crete is extremely
important and the simplest way to do
that to leverage the universal interface
HTTP is make every every idea you you
are l another thing you should do is not
confuse identity with name so thinking
about identity is very important it's
very important if you're going to make
this things work so think careful about
identity and don't confuse identities
with names so what is the name well
here's a nice description of what names
mean in English going back to 1597 this
is Romeo and Juliet you all know the
story right in fact this is one of the
most famous passages in all of the of
the English language and so Juliet
Juliet would have made a terrific API
designer she was she thinks very
carefully and very clearly about about
concepts now what's she saying to Romeo
here is that your name doesn't really
matter your Dame does none does not say
who you are and you can cast off your
name if your name's not convenient you
know doff thy name Romeo which is very
different from your identity right and
so names are terrifically important
things they do have a place in api's
many well-designed API support names but
they do not confuse names with
identities so here's here's an example
here's a good identity this is a pretty
good identity this is a very simple it
doesn't matter what kind of what kind of
resource it is no amount of change you
know this pet oh maybe maybe there's a
problem with this actually because
something that is a pet so for example
if I have a goat this part of a herd
that's really just part of my this was
one of my possessions and then I take
pity on one of these poor sick goats and
take it into my house it became a pet
something changed here right so this
actually might not be a pet might not be
a very good identity because it refers
to a characteristic that might actually
change something that was a pet might
not be a pet if it's just put out in a
field with the other
and kind of animals the important things
about identities is that they're
immutable it isn't they're not based on
some characteristic that might change
and I see lots of people trying to make
identities that look like this and it's
very attractive right because this kind
of @nz one two three four five nobody
can remember that but so but you can
remember that you know lassie was a dog
if you remember the lassie story from
the movie and lastly there was a dog
that belonged to Joe kara Clough
unfortunately lassie was taken away by
the Duke of I forget whatever so not a
very good identity because lassie
changed ownership in the in the movie um
but it is useful to have URLs like this
because it's very useful to be able to
look things up by name even but you have
to be aware that names can names can
change and in fact that brings us to
query so one of the things that I warned
you about is that it's you're basing
basing you basing api's on HTTP is a
very powerful technique but there are
gaps in in HTTP particularly around how
you deal with query and in fact this URL
which is basically saying you know find
the dog or the pet called lassie that
belongs to Joe Carroll Clough is really
can be rewritten this way it's really
just a stylistic difference but both of
these are queries this is not a uri in
the sense it was a uri of a search not
the uri of a dog and it's more if you
write the query if you write the URL
this way it doesn't really change the
meaning but it does make it a little bit
more obvious that in fact this is just
the URL of a query it's not the URL of a
particular dog and it's not guarantee
and because it's a query it's not
guaranteed to give the same real same
result twice let's talk about
representation so representation in HTTP
is the word that is used to mean the
actual format of the resources if I do a
get on a particular resource what I get
back is the representation and jason in
the HTTP world jason is the most common
sort of language that we use for for
writing down those representations but
one of our design problems as an API
designer so you know what should the
Jason look like and there are lots of
options
um if your focus is the first focus that
I talked about that your primary reason
for building an API is for efficient
communication between two components on
the network then the kinds of things
that you're going to focus on is you
want things that are efficient you want
things that are easy to parse you want a
good match for the programming language
on each end you know those are going to
be your sort of primary your primary
values if your focus is how do I make
things easy to integrate and how do I
make things easy to change in the future
your focus is going to be different
you're going to your focus is actually
going to be independence from technology
because you may want to anticipate
different clients of the same API that
will show up at different points in
history and resilience to change is much
more important to you than things like
user parsing and sometimes these are in
conflict so you may have to make up your
mind what's important to you and if
you're working directly with the
implementation teams they have a lot of
biases and they will push for certain
things they won't like homogeneous
collections for example they want things
that are easy to parse and especially if
you work tonight working in a typed
language like Java or NGO or something
like that it's easier to parse things
it's not impossible to parse things if
you don't have this but it's easier to
parse things if you know ahead of time
what the types will be so don't give me
a collection that has a lot of different
types of things in it you know I don't
want this the famous sound of music you
know my favorite things raindrops on
roses and whiskers on kittens right so
those are all different kinds of things
don't put them all in the same
collection because I find that harder to
parse
close to content don't tell me that you
don't know ahead of time what all the
fields are because in my parsing
routines I really like to know what all
the fields are going to be ahead of time
so you know you'll get these kind of
things I'll show you what I mean by
index collections union types aren't
popular don't give me don't give me a
feel that's sometimes a string and
sometimes an object don't really like
that makes it harder for me to parse so
you get lots of these kind of
constraints coming from developers of
things that they don't really like as an
API designer if your goals are the big
problems that I talked about I think you
have to push back on some of these
things some of these things are fine you
know it's not always a good idea to have
a single variable that sometimes a
string and sometimes a number but if it
does make if you think it makes
conceptual sense then maybe you should
put push back on the implementation
teams you've got specific constraints
yeah here's an example of what I mean by
index collection bias and this is
actually I copy the side of an old
Facebook API this may not be current but
there's a Facebook API for listing
photographs and you can see the way the
data is organized is actually reasonably
complicated with my pointer what happens
is that the the outer name in the JSON
thing is actually the user ID and then
the in earth stuff is a set of
photographs for that for that user and
then we start with a second user here
and then we have a block that's the list
of photographs for that user and when
you design Jason this way what you're
really saying is that you're favoring
one particular access pattern for the
data you're assuming that the primary
usage by the client will be that they'll
want to access the photographs based on
the user ID if they wanted to access the
photograph based on creation time or
something like that this is actually not
a very friendly data structure so within
this data structure you've sort of
advantage one set of access patterns and
disadvantaged another set which might be
okay but it might have been better to do
something simpler like this flatten the
whole thing out so if I'd flattened the
whole thing out well first of all it's
simpler because it's much flatter and
what I really did was I took these user
IDs and I moved them into the block this
is going to be less convenient to use if
my primary access method is accessing
the data by user ID but if I'm accessing
it by some other criteria it's actually
better
I actually prefer this
so I prefer the second form because I'm
more open to change five different users
that have different access patterns I
haven't penalized the second set of
users because I optimized my data
representation for the first set of
users even although the first set of
programmers were probably pushing me to
do something like this because they
wanted something that was convenient to
their access pattern um I
I'm very public-spirited so and I have
taken the trouble and to write down a
set of possible rules I'm not claiming
that these are the only rules that you
can that you need to follow and if
you're going to use HTTP well but I
tried to write down a set of rules that
explain how you can use JSON and perhaps
the most simple form possible that that
might be helpful and the reason I like
it is it's more abstract it's less is
less geared towards one particular
access pattern so versioning queries
queries not dealt with by HTTP neither
is versioning and versioning is a very
confusing topic one reason is there's at
least three meanings of versioning and
it's very common when you hear people
talking about versioning for people to
talk past each other because they are
each thinking about versioning a
different way they're thinking about a
different aspect of versioning and you
sometimes find people even getting
themselves confused about using the word
versioning in two different ways in the
same sentence and getting muddled so one
kind of versioning I have dubbed here
entity versioning which says there are
multiple versions so I have a particular
kind of an entity I have a travel trip
or something to stick with our previous
example and I introduced version 1 of
travel trip and then that was successful
for a couple of years and then I had a
major upgrade and we completely reworked
our data model because we reworked our
data model to accommodate some more
advanced scenarios and the old trips and
the new trips are different so every
time I create is so so I introduced a
version two of my
system but when I introduce version 2 I
started creating version 2 trips so
every trip is either a version one trip
or a version to trip but but not both at
the same time so there's a different set
of entities so that's a very common
thing that happens when you make when
you make a major change to your data
model another kind of versioning is what
I dub I have dubbed this is just a
personal vocabulary but I have dubbed
format versioning and what happened
there was I introduced trips and I gave
them one JSON representation and then I
realized from feedback from my customers
they didn't like the names that I chose
for the properties or they didn't like
the way that I organized the jason maybe
from the previous example I'd organized
it the first way and they really
preferred I organized that the second
way or the other way around so I decided
to introduce a version too but the
important thing is that each trip can be
viewed either as through the version one
format or the version 2 format they're
not they're not two different sets of
tropes that the same trips that can be
viewed in two different ways the third
kind of versioning that you hear about
is where you keep Prior revisions of the
same thing so if I have a document a
Google Doc for example and I keep
changing my Google Doc I may have a long
revision history for that for that thing
and you use these in different in
different places you know if you use
entity versioning if you made a
significant structural change to your
data model you use format version
versioning if you're making small
changes to the representation of an
individual entities and you use this and
use historical versioning if you're
doing things like creating an audit
trail and doing undo redo and they're
all different so having got clarity on
that let's look at format versioning
because that's the one that I think
people do most commonly with api's and
let's look at some of the mistakes that
they make so I'm doing format versioning
so one thing that you'll see people
commonly doing is this they put a
version number in a URL that they then
use to try to make a link and that
doesn't really work well and the reason
it doesn't work well is that just
because I wanted version 1 of Lassie
does not mean that I want version 1 of
lassies owner
and in fact the may not even be a
version let's see I asked for version
two of lassie they may not even be a
version two of lassies owner owners may
only have a version one so it's not
possible for the server to select the
version to use in a link so what that
means is you have one or two choices
either you don't put version numbers in
links at all that's one possibility
so that will solve the problem or for
each entity you need to provide a URL
one that does have the version number in
it and one that doesn't and the one that
does not have the version number is the
one that you will use in links and then
customers or clients can transform that
into a URL that does have a version
number if they want to select a
particular version so either of the
strategies will work but what will not
work is trying to use links that have
verse or have trying to use you URLs of
version IDs in them in links so you
might protest that if I if I do this
okay let's say I take all of this stuff
out so I've taken all the version
numbers or version identifiers
out of the URLs but then I've lost some
information well you can put it back if
you like you know invent invent a
property instead for my spine just start
working in very invent a property that
tells you which version number you are
which version format you're looking at
when you're looking at this and if you
also want to give if you want to give
out an ID and also tell me exactly which
version or which version I'm looking at
of the current one or the URL of the
current version you can use something
like this and these values actually
probably probably fit better with the
style of HTTP if we put these in headers
but there's certainly no harm in having
them in properties also a lot of what
we're doing here is just not messing
things up right we've got this Universal
API called HTTP we know how to work it
it works based on URLs just follow the
pattern so as you're designing things
and you're having to add things that are
missing out of HTTP do it in a way that
doesn't make it doesn't mess up the
basics of how a p5 HTTP is actually
so the right way of doing versioning is
every entity has a version free identity
URI you can allow clients to use the
version free identity URI directly by
having an accept version header or you
can allow them to transform the URL into
a different URL that does have the
version identifier in it if you do that
then you're having to provide basically
a transformation algorithm that's
specific to your API it's not a generic
part of the protocol anymore so I'm
gonna wrap up here and invite you to ask
questions but my conclusion slide is
decide what you really care about if you
care primarily in this particular
application that you're doing if you
care primarily about efficient
communication between tightly coupled
components there are lots of great
choices out there G RPC is the one
that's favored by Google and it's a
great choice if you if you're if what
you're focused on is latency and
throughput and efficiency and ease of
programming RPC does all those things
very well if you're aiming for something
more abstract that you're creating your
API is because you're primarily
interested in decoupling systems so that
they're more adaptable to change in the
future or you're primarily interested in
creating api's that will enable
integration scenarios and actually one
of the most important integration
scenarios which I failed to mention
earlier is the one when you're
publishing an API to your partners or
customers so if you're if you're
creating api's that will be consumed
only internally within your own or you
think will only be consumed internally
within your own organization it may be
that the top set of concerns might be
the ones that dominate your thinking if
you're creating ap although actually I
would challenge that but you know anyway
if you but but if you're creating api's
that will be used by other people that
will be consumed by development
organizations over which you have no
control you can't change you can't
control their the rhythm at which they
change things you can't control the way
in which they're the version things and
you can
anticipate all the different ways in
which they will access your data if that
is what you're designing for my
recommendation is don't use an RPC model
use an entity oriented model and in
particular use HTTP JSON as directly and
as simply as possible requiring as
little as possible extra information
about your your specific API that they
cannot glean directly from the internet
standards that's my that's my talk
[Applause]
you
[Music]